peter king is a great friend and uh love
when this man uh has the time to call
into this program and he uh joins us
here on the rich eisen show
mercedes-benz vans
phone line fresh off of yet another
must-read football morning in america
column on nbc sports and pro football
talk mike florio joining us later but
right now i say hello to peter king on
this monday how are you sir
hey rich everything's okay how about you
now i'm glad to hear that very much so
so let's just jump right into it because
i was fascinated by
um your column today and what you wrote
about the overtime rule
and
what do you think has a chance of
passing once it's placed in front of the
membership tomorrow
peter i think i think it's a pretty big
mystery rich but i think those you know
i talked to one
uh top team executive who thought it was
gonna pass easily
um
but
uh and the rule obviously that we're
talking about is
each team getting one possession
in overtime minimum and if after the
second possession the game is tied then
starting with the third possession it's
sudden death um
and so the the nfl the
mo i think most of the people on the
competition committee are in favor of
the rule being changed to that so that
both teams would get a possession in
overtime or be guaranteed a possession
because in the
10 years since the overtime rule
has been enacted
uh essentially what has happened is
there have been 12 games
in the playoffs
that
uh have gone to overtime
and in 10 of those games the team that
won the coin toss to start the overtime
has won the game
seven of those ten games were one on the
first possession of overtime so in seven
of those 12 games
uh the other team the t the coin toss
loser
never saw the uh never saw the ball
and and so rich but i think what is
happening here is that
over time
and look i've been you know covering the
league since the 80s and usually what
you find
is that it's not very easy
to get 24
owners to agree on anything it's not
quite
not quite the current house of
representatives or the senate with the
republican democrat divide but
there's a little bit of that in here
that uh people need to be bashed over
the head to uh change a rule
so
i'm not sure
that there are 24 right now and the two
things that make me a little bit
hesitant number one roger goodell has
not
stated his
preference for this rule
uh he's kind of holding his cards close
to the vest
hasn't said what he favors right now
usually when he tries to push through a
rule it gets pushed through
and number two i also think there
are people who say hey look it's not
been a horrible issue
in all games including regular season
games it's only been bad in the playoffs
so why would we change a rule that
uh really has not been terrible
during the regular season but just has
been one-sided in the playoffs and
that's why
my belief is that owners will do one of
two things
they will either vote to change the rule
for all games so that
uh
you know in the regular season and
postseason
uh the rule will be changed so that both
teams will get one possession
or
they will withdraw
the
if they don't think they have the votes
the 24 votes to win that they'll
withdraw and they'll basically say
okay
let's attempt this year just to do it
for the post season
and then maybe try to do it again in the
future so that's kind of the way i see
it going well i mean
let's just
you know hash this out peter because the
last time
we
you know anytime a rule is proposed and
it's changed everyone talks about what
are the unintended consequences that
will
be born out of this rule change
and i'm just wondering if there might be
some hesitancy on this
rule change just merely because the last
time
there was
a
major to do
born out of a playoff game
that a rule change was uh instituted
it was a total disaster in making
instant re making uh a reviewable play
out of pass interference
and right and and again that's an apple
and this is an orange that we're talking
about but still the idea is to make a
rule change that is significant enough
based on a playoff
uh moment and i'm just wondering what
are the unintended consequences that are
being discussed because of the way i
look at it
i wouldn't want the ball first now
you're basically giving anybody who gets
the ball first in overtime you're kind
of flipping it i want to know exactly
what i need to do and i want to know
exactly what i need to do because i
could be a hell of a lot more aggressive
than the team that gets the ball first
because of it you know so how does that
fix anything
i totally agree with you i think that
most teams
if both teams are guaranteed one a
possession to start overtime
i think it could do a couple of things
neither which is bad uh number one it
could
it could obviously i think most teams
will defer
uh
most if not all will defer because
obviously if you win the coin toss
theoretically you should get some
small advantage
theoretically
and that would seem to me to be
that you would possess the ball second i
think the strategic things rather than
talking about
unintended bad consequences i think
there are some cool strategic things
number one
if let's just say that you win the toss
and you defer
and so team
team a now who gets the ball first
they score a touchdown and they say okay
well geez we got we got patrick mahomes
on the other side so what we're going to
do is we're going to head him off at the
pass we're going for two right now
so let's say they go for two and make it
so now kansas city gets the ball team b
and they have to go and score a
touchdown
and get a two-point conversion and then
you know the first team is going to get
the ball back if indeed that's how it
happens but
i think there's a lot of things that
could happen if this rule is passed
but none of them are remotely
as egregious
in terms of basic fairness
to say that you know in the last four
years we have seen josh allen
of the buffalo bills be on the wrong end
of the coin toss and not get a chance to
touch the ball in overcut
and we have seen patrick mahomes against
tom brady in 2018
not get a chance to possess the ball
even though
kansas city in that particular game was
hot as a firecracker
and so those are the things that in my
opinion rich are worse
than any strategical things that would
come about
uh
you know changing this rule
i hear you peter but
i don't know i mean
so um
we heard tomlin basically here's the
question here's the question all right
in the last 36 overtime games the last
36 yes
the team that won the toss
elected to receive the ball
the last time a team won the toss and
elected to defer and to defend a goal
was mike tomlin in 2019 when duck hodges
was his quarterback and he was playing a
great defense the baltimore raven
which is totally understandable but 36
times in a row the coin flip determined
who got a huge advantage in a game which
is getting the ball first and if you
score a touchdown the game is over
in my opinion yes i don't understand why
that isn't more
doesn't lend to more i don't even want
to say outrage
but the sense of unfair play
and the the sense of influence
the the silly flip of a coin has on huge
football games well and and the silly
flip of a coin that happens um
right after 60 minutes is played and
blood sweat and tears have been spilled
and
now we're we're in a whole different
ball of whack strategically clockwise
uh that the the toss is then is then
done there the idea that one of the
callers to this show peter came up with
that i really dig a lot
is that you tie the opening coin toss of
the game to whether you get the decision
to
in overtime so if you win the opening
coin toss and you defer
you're giving the ball to start overtime
to your opponent
you know and and and then you don't
mandate both teams touch it and you play
it out just the way it goes
and you know if you lose it's just like
well then you're the one who gave them
the ball to start and we've known that
for three and a half real-time hours so
we're not sitting there shocked at oh
god that just happened it's just like
well that's on you because you wanted to
defer you wanted the ball to start the
second half you've coughed that up and
you just play it out you know because
again i i just find that we're just
going to be moving the deck chairs we're
just going to be complaining about
something else like well of course that
team won because they knew they had to
go for it they had to go for it on
fourth and three from their own 33-yard
line which the team that gets the ball
to start overtime wouldn't have to do of
course they're gonna punt it and play
for another day because they have the
ability to you know the the team that
gets it second can play it a totally
different way than the team that gets it
first i i don't that's why i don't like
it you know like we're just going to be
talking about something completely else
that's all but what's more unjust
what is more unjust
what you saw happen to
uh when when look
the defenses in the in these two games
yes that that i bring up mostly yes
the kansas city new england afc
championship game
and then the kansas city buffalo
divisional game yes in both of those
games yes
you know offenses have changed in
football
some of them are so incredibly
overpowering
that they have just beaten up the
opposing defense the whole game
and so what happens is you get to
overtime and why do you think anything
is going to be different after kansas
city has scored 36 points against
buffalo
during regulation how do you have any
hope that buffalo is going to stop him
in overtime
i i mean and conversely
you know
the chiefs were getting track meeted by
tom brady and and the and hey look and
and so was uh new england's defense by
mahomes
my only point in all this and rich i
don't mind that
um i don't mind
that
your your thought about the coin flip or
whoever came up with that right i guess
i guess what i say is
you know how owners are
right people who get proposed something
like that coin flip rule they're just
going to say that's too complicated for
me
or i don't like it i don't like it it
doesn't make sense it's all this all i'm
saying is
we're going to argue about this stuff
and what you like and don't like and
then
you know so nothing gets done
and then there's going to be the same
rule
that prevents
basic fairness in a football game
which is
if it wasn't that big a deal the coin
flip why have 36 coaches in a row all
chosen to take the ball when they win
the flip to start overtime
and that to me
is the madness we're gonna we're gonna
argue over all these various things
instead of just saying okay i don't love
this one but it's better than the
current system so
let's let's at least get this one
and then let's try to see if we can get
owners to see that hey the coin flip at
the start of the game
that's going to dictate what could start
overtime so
you know
that's all i'm saying that
there can be all kinds of great ideas
but a great idea is not necessarily an
idea that's going to pass muster with 24
of 32 owners
and uh before i let you go uh peter king
uh part of your column was that the
browns owners aren't uh really having
rose petals thrown at their feet at the
breakers hotel right upon their arrival
for the owner's meeting right now you
know i think everybody is going to be
cordial
to the haslams
uh to jimmy and dee haslam
uh
because they're cordial people but i
think that
not only uh are there a lot of owners
and a lot of club people who think that
it's gross
to
pay a guy the biggest contract in nfl
history when he's got 22 civil cases
involving sexual impropriety hanging
over his head
and
you know it's it's also
i wouldn't say gross but in the attempt
to justify it
uh you know what
there is no justification at least look
i'm different than a lot of people in
this i don't think there's any
justification for this
there are times in life when you say gee
i'd love to have that bright shiny
object
but it cost eight billion dollars and
there's something basically wrong here
instead of saying we'll give you 230
million dollars
it'd be far better to say hey listen
let's see what happens when all these
cases are adjudicated and if we lose you
because of that if we if we don't get
you then that's the way it goes
but we would rather have our honor than
uh than than make a business decision
like this which there's not a soul in
the world
who can tell anybody that this is this
is all going to turn out roses this is a
risky
play by the haslems and by the cleveland
browns we'll see how it goes but i just
think there's a lot of people in the
league who object
who think that it is it's amoral to have
done this and not just that i i i mean
i'm just talking about as well
that uh you know i'm sure kyler murray's
uh negotiation whatever the the state of
play was between
he and the cardinals uh that changed the
minute every guaranteed dollar was was
every dollar given to desean watson was
guaranteed i mean
will we ever see a contract
again it's not fully guaranteed right to
have a to have a contract given to
uh
any player
that is the greatest contract in nfl
history never mind one with the sort of
damocles hanging over desean watson's
head
is incredible to a lot of people around
the league but you're right he changed
the business for all great quarterbacks
in the nfl there's no question about it
and i think what you're going to see
rich and i've talked to a couple of
people about this i i think you're going
to see
because no one now
is going to want to say like you're
patrick mahomes okay we're giving you a
10-year deal and it's all going to be
guaranteed all these contracts now i
think are going to be shorter
because they're going to have to
guarantee the money
and the guarantee system in the nfl in
case people don't know
is is is a is real guarantee you have to
put the money up
and so that's
no
you know clark hunt is not going to say
hey
let's put 450 million dollars in that's
good
for our quarterback it's just not going
to happen
so i guess in the minute i have left
with you what's the quick snapshot of
baker mayfield i mean what you know
kevin stefanski said today once
so i keep thinking that
you know what's standing in the way with
baker mayfield is he's got 18.9 million
guaranteed basically
if somebody picks him up or takes his
contract and why would he give up a dime
of that
but if you're seattle or your carolina
or your whoever and you say we don't
even know if baker mayfield's going to
be our guy beyond one year
we don't we don't know that right now we
would prefer to spend
and i'm going to make this up we'd
prefer to spend
you know 7 million on teddy bridgewater
or
or someone of that ilk
i mean we don't
we don't want to pay a guy 19 million
when we really don't have any idea if
he's going to be our guy long term so i
think that
is what's standing in the way of baker
mayfield right now peter king thanks for
the time greatly appreciate it you'd be
well everyone no problem rich enjoyed it
thank you right back at you at peter
underscore king everyone should check
out his uh
his story hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that watch more right
here